[Musique]
fou
sévigny situé en plein coeur du bouveret
alexandre monmousseau les regarde tous
les jours avec amour créé au xviie
siècle
elles appartiennent à sa famille depuis
trois générations mais depuis quelques
années elles sont attaquées par un
champignon qui fait beaucoup de dégâts
dans les vignobles français les ce cas
là ça va pas très bien
le lam de la feuille des quasiment
nécrosés en fait tout ça c'est lié au
fait que la cei ne peut plus passer la
maladie des os cassés l'obturation des
vaisseaux c'est c'est le cholestérol
dont la plupart des cas l'esc a fini par
tuer les pieds de vigne et depuis
l'interdiction il ya une dizaine
d'années de l'arsénite de sodium un
produit très toxique
il n'existe plus de traitements
efficaces alors ici on s'est lancé dans
une expérience originale on diffuse une
musique qui adoucit les moeurs
[Musique]
e
non
un panneau photovoltaïque une batterie
un autoradio est un programmateur et
puis et puis la séquence alors on fait
passer deux fois par jour le matin le
soir pendant tout le cycle végétatif on
y va jusqu'à la halle à à la chute des
feuilles et puis vous voyez les vignes
n'ont pas l'air malheureux
la technique consiste à rendre
l'agresseur et l'agressé tolérant lala
envers l'eau c'est-à-dire qu'on rend la
maladie moins agressive et dans le même
temps on rend le sujet agressé moins
sensible et l'intérêt de la méthode
c'est que on garde les deux ensemble ça
veut dire qu'on n'est plus dans une
lutte d'éradication
on est dans une dans un principe de
tolérance et ça c'est très intéressant
pourquoi parce que l'éradication crel
vite que la nature bouge tout de suite
par autre chose ça s'appelle les effets
secondaires et là en fait il n'y a pas
de trou le méchant et moi méchant et le
le bris mais il est moins brimés
sur la parcelle traité seuls 150 pieds
sont morts l'année dernière contre 850
l'année précédente grâce à la diffusion
de ces sont baptisés protée audi un
terme inventé par le chercheur joël
sternheimer depuis 40 ans ce docteur en
physique théorique étudie les particules
élémentaires les ondes et la musique
il a découvert qu'on peut stimuler ou
inhiber la production de protéines de
tous les organismes vivants en les
exposant à des ondes produites par
certains champs
je fus rappeler ses vieilles histoires
que j'entendais est enfant un musique de
mozart qui fait donner du meilleur
relais aux vaches je me suis dit si ça
se trouve la prolactine qui fait
intervenir qui fait venir le lait des
vaches ça doit faire du mozart alors je
suis allé chercher la séquence de la
prolactine et on a donc une c'est une
suite de lettres qui courait qu'il
exprime chacune un acide aminé ces
lettres t pvc et png ce sont des lettres
différentes des acides aminés différence
mais il se trouve que leur fréquence
propre sont les mêmes parce qu'elles ont
des masses qui sont pratiquement
identiques et qui en fait on est amené
au coeur qu'elle se synchronise et donc
si je me met à chanter ça qu'est ce que
j'obtiens tilila gilad à quillan à lille
haddad a t'il al ahdath al hilal
ça c'est du mozart
oui moi connais de l'animal qui inventa
le calcul intègre à mettre la musique en
équation pour en étudier les effets sur
la matière c'est un travail que joël
sternheimer a entamé à l'université
américaine de princeton
en 1967 la télévision française
s'intéresse et déjà lui mais ce qui lui
valait cette notoriété c'est la carrière
de chanteur qui menait à l'époque sous
le pseudonyme d'evariste en hommage au
mathématicien evariste galois dernières
heures un nouveau venu dans la chanson
lien tout droit d'amérique jax albert
l'a rencontré à l'université de
princeton c'est eva risque
audrey dû intégrer des équations été
jours sais tu que quand on fait des
épures tout ce qu'on attrape et les
courbatures
moi j'en ai eus quand j'étais tout dans
un style proche d'antoine jacques
dutronc evariste a poursuivi sa carrière
de chanteur jusqu'au milieu des années
70 les bénéfices engrangés par la vente
de ces 33 tours y ont permis ensuite de
financer ses recherches en restant
indépendant des financements publics à
wadi on aime et varient et maristes
voilà il arrive pendant des années
lorsqu'il venait une inspiration
musicale j'avais besoin d'exprimer
quelque chose dont josé une chanson et
depuis que je travaille sur les pros
théo dit je trouve ça beaucoup plus
intéressant continue via une inspiration
musicale de trouver avec kate protéines
j'étais en contact qui était la source
de mon inspiration et de la décoder
parce qu'à ce moment là c'est
effectivement un soin préventif
et puis il faut bien dire que c'est le
pied quand on quand on trouve la protège
ni dont on a besoin
la génomique contraction de génétique et
mélodique
c'est le nom que joël sternheimer a
donnés à la science qu'il a fondé ces
principes sont impossible à comprendre
pour le commun des mortels qui ne
possèdent pas de solides notions de
physique quantique
tout le monde en revanche pu observer
ses applications pratiques
elles sont commercialisées par
l'entreprise génomique ce que le
chercheur a créé avec quelques associés
et ça eh ben ça veut dire qu'on se
rapproche de la solution puisqu'il ya
une baisse dès ce cas très importante
dans les 75 % en moyenne
genot l'x et compte aujourd'hui 80
clients quelques maraîchers et une
cinquantaine de viticulteurs convaincu
notamment par les propositions
commerciales de l'entreprise
on s'engage absolument à rembourser
intégralement
c'est à dire que pour lescar par exemple
s'il n'y a pas au moins 30% de baisse de
la mortalité et bien on propose de
rembourser ou de recommencer une
deuxième année gratuitement
c'est souvent d'ailleurs ce qui se passe
le vit on dit oui bon il ya un résultat
mais c'est pas entièrement convaincant
mais vrai est ce qu'on peut pas faire
mieux bon et retravailler une deuxième
année c'est et en maraîchage c'est
pareil une fois sur deux les clients
nous propose des problèmes qu'on n'a
jamais traité
[Musique]
depuis quatre ans les protêts audi
réveille chaque matin et berceau tous
les soirs les salades de christian de
conac
ce maraîcher installé dans un petit
village de basse-normandie a été l'un
des premiers à tenter l'expérience
une année où des envies de santé
l'avaient empêché d'effectuer les
traitements chimiques conventionnelle
pendant enfin un mois et demi s'était
planté et il n'y a pas eu aucun
traitement ni même de désherbage ni quoi
que ce soit elle n'est pas traitée et
tous les ans depuis qu'on a construit la
serre ça se dégrade ce que le sol su ça
s'abîme enfin le solde y est grosso modo
et on avait de plus en plus de cela de
malades et en enfin cet hiver-là on a eu
beaucoup moins de malades c'était la
première fois que ça arrivait en vingt
ans donc il y avait un effet il y avait
un effet ces quatre dernières années il
ya eu ici des résultats plus ou moins
bon selon les saisons mais l'exploitant
reste fidèle à la méthode
malgré son coût 1700 euros par an
trois fois plus cher qu'à un traitement
chimique conventionnel mais l'abandon
des pesticides comporte de nombreux
avantages
[Applaudissements]
c'est moins de produits et puis c'est
vrai c'est du temps en moins c'est ya
pas la pression de trouver quelqu'un
pour le faire et c'est le stress quand
on quand on traite qu'on a le masque à
gaz etc
les gants c'est compliqué c'est
stressant on n'a pas ça la touche tous
fait tout seul même on peut être là on
ne peut ne pas être là quand le
le son est émis
voilà ça c'est tout seul
[Musique]
dans une petite exploitation quand on
vend soi même ses salades chaque minute
gagnée compte sur les marchés christian
de coninck hésitent encore un peu a
expliqué ses secrets de fabrication aux
clients enfin on s'est moqué et puis on
se moque encore enfin un peu de moi de
moins en moins mais bon on se moque un
peu de moi mais bon pas de problème moi
si j'ai un résultat pour se moquer de
moi
les précurseurs on se pose toujours 2
[Musique]
chez de la est l'un des plus gros
maraîchers d'indre et loire
on n'est pas là pour rigoler
l'entreprise emploie une quarantaine de
salariés
elle produit chaque année 700 tonnes
d'endives destiné pour l'essentiel à la
grande distribution elle aussi grandi en
écoutant les trotter audi ici le but
n'est pas de réduire la quantité de
produits phytosanitaires mais tout
simplement de leur donner une bonne
c'est la troisième campagne que l'on
fait avec ce dispositif pas voyez
produits produits propres lesquels il
est en pleine forme les brillantes elles
et pas comme on les aime l'hiver quand
la saison des représentations le plein
celle des concombres commence dans cette
serre on prépare la campagne 2014 et en
même temps qu'on effectue les
traitements préventifs un des associés
de genoptix vient installer les haut
parleurs pour diffuser les séquences
sonores spécialement adaptés à cette
culture dont classe essentiellement sur
le métabolisme sur la photosynthèse
aussi parce qu'on est dans une période
bien sûr il ya peu de lumière les jours
son cours et il ya peu de lumière donc
aider la planta mieux faute au sein des
10 et et à mieux croître mieux sans
incident
en fait j'ai changé la disquette parce
que ça c'est la scène de la dernière là
on va mettre celle de début de
croissance
notre première campagne de concombres
sur cette serre si on a mis la séquence
pour l'activation de croissance et on a
gagné une semaine de récolte
supplémentaires les plantes ont produit
leurs fruits une semaine plus vite que
d'habitude et à telle enseigne que au
début je pensais m'être trompé sur ma
date de plantation et en y regardant de
fois je dis donc c'est pas trompé c'est
bien on a bien planté ce jour là
aujourd'hui on est le temps ça fait que
quatre semaines alors qu'à d'habitude
ces cinq semaines et demi à 6 outre
l'effet sur la croissance les protège au
10e ont surtout permis l'année dernière
de sauver une partie de la récolte qui
était attaqué par une maladie moi je
suis ici ville par un technicien sur la
lutte biologique intégrée qui vient tous
les mois ou tous les mois et demi et
juste après l'attaqué il a vu qu
effectivement les conforme était en
train de mourir
il est revenu à un mois et demi plus
tard à son retour de congés et première
question qui m'a posé ses tiens vous
avez replanter j'ai dit non c'est
strictement les mêmes concours ils m'ont
dit mais vous leur avez fait quoi
j'aurais dit on leur a mis de la musique
pour les ingénieur agronome de formation
classique gêne au dic rime plutôt avec
ésotérique
difficile d'imaginer que les principes
de la physique quantique peuvent avoir
un impact sur la culture des
cucurbitacées
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce sont deux mondes qui sont
effectivement très très loin les uns des
autres
un biochimiste va rien comprendre la
physique quantique que pour pour
caricaturer et un physicien va trouver
la biologie presque trop simple pour lui
et vous travaillez à la synthèse des
deux et nous montre effectivement sur
les bleus le gala que
en courgettes dans le sud est même si
les producteurs constate des résultats
concrets la gêne au dic n'est pas encore
une discipline reconnue par des
organismes tels que l'inra ou le cnrs
joël sternheimer et ses collaborateurs
travaillent en marge des grandes
universités
l'un des rares scientifiques de renom a
validé ses recherches et le biologiste
jean marie pelt
je pense que nous sommes sur une piste
ça m'intéresse beaucoup pour cette
raison-là cette piste c'est de
considérer comme le veut la physique
quantique la matière comme étant
corpusculaire et vibratoires on a
toujours considéré la matière comme
corpusculaire évidemment la matière
materi a dit lui dire mais on a pas que
tu comptes des vibrations qui sont
spécifiques à chaque type de molécules
et lui fait entendre par une musique ils
composent et qui est approprié à la
molécule qu'il veut stimuler du point de
vue de ses fonctions et on obtient là
des résultats qui laissent penser que
c'est une voie nouvelle pour la science
qui peut s'ouvrir et je pense que ça
peut être une discipline d'avenir ça
peut faire faire un bond en avant très
important pour la biologie la prochaine
étape importante ce sera la publication
dans une grande revue scientifique et
c'est à ça que travail le laboratoire
public franck d'un combat de caen ici
les protéines sont pas testés sur des
salades ou des grappes de raisin mais
sur des animaux en l'occurrence des
huîtres des huîtres malades infectés par
un virus qui fait des ravages dans les
bassins et contre lequel tout le monde
cherche un remède le virus il est connu
depuis très très longtemps virus en
france on l'a découvert depuis 1981
un 19,91 donc lio c'est connu depuis
très longtemps mais c'est surtout avec
les surmortalités qui sont survenus en
on s'est intéressé à ce virus et c'est
là qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il avait
qui l'avait muté et qu'on est en
présence d'un nouveau variant qui était
le
virus micro var dans une pièce du
laboratoire se trouve à bloc un témoin
avec des huîtres malades non exposés
hausse à l'autre bout du bâtiment celle
que nous voyons ici subissent les pros
théo dit matin et soir
l'année dernière ce protocole avait été
mise en place pour la première fois avec
un résultat intéressant dix fois moins
de mortalité du côté des huîtres est
donc là on est en train d'essayer de
remettre en place la même manipulation
c'est à dire on a déjà observé qu'en
effet envoyé une différence de mortalité
entre les animaux qui subissaient des
pros tennis et qui ont subi c'est pas
maintenant ça peut être un fait du
hasard donc la biologie et n'est jamais
répétable donc il faut faire de
nombreuses fois ces manipulations pour
pouvoir voir si en effet il ya une
action sera sur le virus ou pas
si les résultats sont confirmés cela
renforcera la crédibilité de genoptix
qui a déjà menées ailleurs des
expériences sur l'élevage des porcs et
des chèvres
la société ne communique pas en revanche
sur les éventuelles applications
médicales du procédé
car quand on soigne l'animal on peut
soigner l'homme un animal comme les
autres en france le sujet des médecines
parallèles et sensible le secteur
médical est extrêmement réglementé mais
joli sternheimer et là aussi persuadé
l'efficacité de sa méthode il l'a
constaté pour la première fois il ya
près de 30 ans avec une amie à lui
dont le taux d'hémoglobine était
anormalement bas et donc je vais
proposer qu'est ce que tu veux écouter
ta molécule elle a dit oui et donc j'ai
fait défiler la suite des notes et a dit
écoute il se passe quelque chose je sens
quelque chose de très fort en moi tu
veux pas la repasser et c'est ce que
j'ai fait même en fredonnant par dessus
elle m'a dit écoute je ressens quelque
chose de fort là j'étais épuisée je me
sens beaucoup mieux
j'ai l'impression d'être guéri et vous
vous utilisez les protéines dit vous
même pour vous soigner
évidemment mais ça c'est un gros
problème parce qu on en bénéficie
les enfants aussi et leurs camarades de
classe il en parle
alors où est ce que ça s'arrête ça
devient nécessaire que il ya une
évaluation et pas seulement par un petit
groupe parce que sinon ça va mener une
situation de confrontation qui serait
dommageable avant tout dans cette danse
dans ce type de choses mais une
évaluation qui puisse être observés
largement
les recherches sur les salades la vigne
ou les huîtres ne sont qu'une étape pour
valider cette théorie mais le but ultime
de la génomique est bien de soigner
l'être humain un horizon encore très
lointain mais c'est le risque
[Musique]